all right welcome everyone to the stream
were all be talking about basic
strategies for openings and the middle
games for beginners and I'll try to
explain what the most important
strategies are what basically to look
out for and what are the what what would
what people should do what not to do and
I will show some examples of of that and
how to apply it and so second i'm gonna
start with with trying to explain what
is most important thing were the most
important things so first mapping there
are three very important factors that
people should think about while playing
chess the first one and they're all
equally important they kind of coexist
together so the first one is center
control of the center center are
basically force force and transfers that
in the animal of the board and basically
who controls them you know has the them
kind of is in charge of the game in
general has more space it has more kind
of like possibilities for to move their
people move his pieces and in general it
gives more opportunities to win the game
then you can attack inside queenside
whatever you think is sensible this is
one thing second thing apart from center
is the development of pieces piece
activity and having in mind control of
the center basically you can play with
your pieces and active piece play gives
you you know possibilities to win the
game so if you develop your pieces you
can
create threads grab material things like
that and the first thing which is the
sort of not very important won't say
more important because all the mark
might be equally important but like
especially in poor Novak put like this
is the kink safety if because if your
king is safe you'll not get mated but I
give your king is in danger you make it
made it no matter how well your pieces
are placed and the reviews have to
always watch out for your king that's
why I will try to show here in this in
this sort of like class what at first
what not to do let's say in the opening
and slash middle game so let's say Y
plane before which is very sensible and
logical move and if normal response
would be of course let's say for
instance if I for c5 which will lead to
normal openings but let's say black
doesn't kind of care about Center and
doesn't care about peace development and
just play some random moves with pawns
a6 for instance
all right so white goes before which is
the new normally the think you know it's
correct to the develop you know do I
mean to control center open the bishop
on c1 and open knight on c3 as well from
everyone you just can go Knight c3 which
over 493 you know develop your pieces so
this is the white employees correct
strategy but the black on the other hand
just ignores its place h6 so let's see
what happens in like some example you
know example scenario that can happen in
the game with black let's say ignores
you know the rules of you know center
development and King safety because this
is
it's because in my mine is very
instructive so dicey free is logical is
six another pawn move neither three what
does everything according to the you
know to the do the rules night of
developing pieces be five we should be
free again and again black should of
course start developing pieces right now
we should be 797 Knight f6 maybe I think
maybe not the great let's move but still
better than just you know randomly
pushing pawns so but black plays before
and trying to - let's say attack this I
know see free asking what it does so
first of all it's not the not not
correct to play like this because we
know pieces so let's say what goes 9a
for logical move and black continues the
strategy of pushing pawns forward which
is very bad poem play obviously ignoring
all the development while white has the
control in the center and already free
pieces in the game so let's see what
happens white castles King is already
safe in the same in the end
on the kingside g4 another bad move of
course this is an example of bad play
for black well the black should not be
doing and then I will show what black
should do normal and like typical
opening / middle games that you know can
arise in the game of in games of
grandmasters and like you know anyone
who can achieve them
I've only they'd start developing pieces
normally so this is what we are not
supposed to do G 495 active move
attacking the pawn on g-force okay if
while attacks normally black should
defend so h5 and suddenly a free and
this already opens the f5 potential FF
file potentially and it will decide only
five sort of hitting this pawn on f7
we read this rook opening here Queen
coming in here it starts getting great
arrayed bad for black very very
dangerous position so let's say black
plays d6 try to harass the knife and
already white has possibility of
sacrificing here the night and basically
attacking the King opening the king so
that's in attacks of 7 why not King
takes f7 pawn takes already opens the F
file and how attacking the King
and King has to come back and for
instance black or white his name's Quinn
a phrase possible there are many many
was possible but I really like your if I
for instance because the movie five
creates a big front of Bishop g6 and the
queen of three as well and this if you
like if you notice black hasn't made any
move the piece while white already made
like several moves with the pieces and
they created some early making attack
protected it's on King 2g 102 the King
side and it has wonderful piece play
because queen of three is coming and
Bishop d6 is coming so what may happen
for instance if black suddenly starts
finally developing pieces Knight d7 for
instance of course is terrible move I
mean possibly push the person who just
lost I mean this lost so Bishop g6 King
is 7 of course we have 7 wins but just
to show what that white can simply
improve another piece to the game Bishop
g5 is not the best new best movies
obviously rogue f7 is just made in few
moves but also Bishop g5 is possible
which certainly wins here so that's the
so that's the big problem here for
blight that already position is lost
we simply because black didn't develop
any pieces and this was black I mean if
what was doing following the same
strategy point pawns black would do the
same thing this is what neither player
should be playing with only pounces why
pieces are are supporting pawns no
they're not don't stop that they don't
start falling this way some reason so
yeah this is what you're not supposed to
do in well playing chess all right so
let's see what you should do
what kind of typical openings we call
possibilities you may have in the game
so I will show what happens right now if
white plays if like what happens after
typical openings after d4 so d4 is like
you know one of the possible moves to
start the game before and let's say how
having in mind was free concepts cuz
kinks okay centers control of the center
piece play the open of piece slash
development pieces and kink safety how
all those strategies apply in let's say
a regular modern theory of openings and
middle games so let's say d4 Knight f6
this is and let's say this will be
Catalan opening and you guys can see how
how white and black develops its pieces
now the 3d five okay both sides control
the center equally g3 white wants to
develop Bishop to g2 Bishop e7 Bishop g2
short cut so short Castle he takes c4
Queen c2 a6 Queen takes c4
grabbing the pawn Barbie five Queen c2
Bishop d7 and here we have the position
that basically both sides are perfectly
developed relatively what has to move
the bishop from d2 summer night from b1
as well black has to develop 9:27 but
for instance there is a line like Bishop
g5 for instance there is 97 the same she
takes f6 Knight takes f6 Knight d2 rook
c8 night be free
sorry proceed not be free and this is
sort of numb not a normal position were
both sides are very well developed both
Kings are safe both sides both by one
and I control the center and position is
pretty much balanced and here from here
basically the entire strategical fight
begins it doesn't happen you know you
can you here think about Kevin but some
of like c5 we should before you know
mayor many many moves here is a
theoretical position so yeah this is how
it works and this is how you apply for
the saying those ideas in Catalan here
we will go back a little bit and we'll
see if white not doesn't go Catalan but
let's say a Queens gambit declined
Knight c3 and Bishop e7 it's classical
line with g5 Bishop h4 we showed Castle
in three pieces Pulaski I think even I'm
mistaken we should be free we should be
seven short Castle 9b d7 again both
sides castle Kings are safe both maybe
White has slightly slightly more control
descent because of this pawn on c4 but
in general is pretty much balanced and
both sides develop all the pieces first
night and bishops castle everything is
perfect let's say Queenie to c5 right
now black equality controls the center
maybe way slightly better here simply
because there is like there is one extra
move for a while because Y star def
sorry first but it's not a big deal sort
of you know it's like you know typical
open position from the opening that can
happen in games of Grand Master and to
be honest I think there are like 1,000
games this position is the database so
this is what you know you should sort of
like one example what you would you
should does white or black basically
develop all the pieces control the
center castle make your king is safe
things like that and let's say from the
other side let's say if black plays g6
to g7 says a girl out opening it it's
grown fast so here Knight c3 g5 Bishop
g7 allows Kings Indian defense which is
also possible obviously but it as as I
said it gives white control of the
center so it's a little Grandmaster
level is not considered as the best
opening however it's very very possible
playable as well but in general in terms
Lecter from Terra Cotta perspective
let's say the groom fall is likes a
little bit better opening and congenial
hurricanes and also perfectly playable
65 925 if 493 BC and yes he white
controls the center but the thing is
that black he has some active play to
attack the center mezzo c5 b 92 96
of course developing pieces we should be
free castle castle making sure our king
is safe and right now black has variety
of options of attacking the center and
trying to maintain equality let's say
Bishop g4 is one possibility trying to
pin the knight and queen for provoking
with some weakness f3 the submission d7
it's some weakness and basically CD CD
64 64 will happen at some point there's
possibility of Queen c7 rook 88 for
black it crew and putting some pressure
on the D file so it's not even though
White has that says advantage of the
center here will convert the center it's
not really kind of significant because
black also puts lots of pressure in the
center and with active pieces like the
submission g7 and which knight on c6
developing queen to Stan Raimondi 8
there is enough conversation for the
deficit of the center here so it's under
opening and finally let's say this is
Slava opening sort of Moran
I'll go from beginning d4 d5 c4 c6
Knight f3 knight c6 Knight f6 again
developing pieces controlling equally
the center maybe my wife has a little
bit more control the center because it's
spawn c4 is there and was normal in
because when I started the game so this
normal six
if 397 Quincy to Bishop d6 all
developing pieces all the normal
developing moves b3 short Castle Bishop
e2 v6 Bishop b2b should be seven short
Castle Queen seven room d138
rookie one rookie eight and as you guys
can see the position is perfectly fine
for both white and black and from here
the entire strategy strategical fight
goes on but here basically begins the
main vertical position in this Moran
Slav Moran opening and here what can
play through a four I can play for
Bishop f1 g3 start with g3 there are
lots of strategical plans whether marm
farmer advance and there are beyond of
the scope of this of this sort of
tutorial of the openings I'm showing
right now but basically from this
position it all starts let's say rather
than playing random moves at the
beginning of the game with bones so
these are typical opens after d4 let's
let's look at what happens with typical
openings after E for because it's also
interesting to do to see what happens if
white starts with E for let me just open
the chessboard if or so before and
they're basically for typical opening
for main openings that white black and
employ however others are also playable
but let's say if for e5 is possible if
for C 5 is Sicilian if for East exist
sorry a for e cigs is French
if vs. is kurakin so all of them are
perfectly playable in all of them also
example of the lines were both sides are
trying to you know apply those concepts
of
center of impede the between the pieces
of developing the pieces and finally
King safety so let's say if for let's
start with French for instance if we 6d
45 if French is by the way a favorite
opening of Baraka bein
the chief I think of are also imposed
the c5 here so Edie Edie 9 f3 knight c6
other moves Queen takes d5 but let's for
the sake of simplicity just like the
poem becomes one of the examples at the
396 we shall be 5 a Bishop d6 again
developing pieces Castle 97 Black is a
little bit behind right now in
development because black has in the
cast of the pieces because it hasn't
castled yet but as we will see it will
happen very shortly so detects c4 dxe5
Bishop takes d5 93 Bishop d6 for
instance rugby one short Castle and
right now everything is past again the
same Bishop g5 Bishop g4 and in this
position again it all just begins you
know both sides developed pieces both
created some fresh already and from here
the entire strategical battle may I mean
lie just begin begins and so this is one
of the examples how to apply those
concepts here both sides for sort of
control the center wife as my Black has
maybe isolate the pawn on d5 but on the
other hand it gives some more space for
their pieces so it's pretty much
balanced position and this is what one
of the example of what you should do
open in the opening with white and black
enamel recovery are playing with so the
second caro-kann let's say caro-kann d5
they're also there's if I order he takes
d5 move but I want to focus on a c3 just
for example Knight takes e4 Bishop a5
classical line the g3 Bishop g6 H 4 H 6
9 f3 97
h5 shop h7 we should be free trade
involve bishops Quinta xD free and right
now black has I'm a little bit like
problems I mean not ray black is a
little bit you know behind white and in
terms of you know
pieces here they are playing in the game
but on the other hand positions very
solid so black can basically try to make
ketchup and this would black does let's
say e sixth we should be 296 to on Cosmo
we shall be seven King be one short
castle and very quickly black already
caught up and here from here basically
the entire surgical bulb again begins
from here not from move number one where
basically you just have to first develop
your pieces and then rather than push
pawns and then right now for instance
White has idea the thing that if for
with idea of playing GG for den and g5
trying to then push pawns you know to
create let's say open the g5 for drugs
let's say if Queen that's a c7 or
something with the wharf consideration
tree for Knight takes d4 and the rook a
g1 a rogue DG one let's say group h g1
and basically the idea is that right now
only move as a five because if Knight
xf6 even I becomes like this image of h6
and already here is there is some you
know attack for white but on the other
hand black can let the attack in the
center of c5 so here let's say pawn
moves and our let's say more kind of
like in place or earlier simply because
they are supported by the pieces are
already develop in the game so that's
the idea so this is kurakin and let's
finally show if for let's say Sicilian
and Sicilian this would be another
classical opening neither 3 d6 d4 will
go for an either back and back get to
Scheveningen nice III a6 Bishop e2
is 6 for instance choked sob should be
7a for short Castle perfect development
from both sides we should be free knight
c6 king h1 Queen c7 a 48 preferred oven
from both sides and right now for
instance black can go what nope should
be free where I can go Queen e1 trying
to basically I try to attack on the King
side well whereas black will try to
create some central play with E 5 for
instance so but again it only all
happens after all pieces are in the game
not before so this is another type of
opening that you guys can play and
finally a 45 will enter here I will show
briar opening a brave version in the
Spanish defense Spanish game more like
maybe should be 5 a 6 a bishop a 4/9 of
six short caso Bishop e7 rugby 1 b5 we
should be free shot g6 c free short
castle h3 and right now there there is
there are a lot of possibilities for for
black there is night eight fighters we
should be seven different different
lines but I want just to show maybe
because it's very very nice how black in
regroup here before 9b d7 IBT tube
should be seven again developing all the
pieces yeah coming back here maybe I'd
made some look a little bit weird
because it's just my came to see c6 from
ba but it is I can like comes to d7 to
support the center and doesn't stay in
the way of Bishop on b7 so this is what
happens we should be seven normally I'm
a c6 this I wouldn't be so greatly
placed I think simply because this
ambition we said would be covered but
right now it's hitting on e4 causing
some problems for it and why this wood
shop c2 Ruby 8 9 f1 we should have eight
nine g3 and g6 bishop comes to g7 and
this is sort of you know again the
recomposition here like what has lots of
possibilities same as Black has lots of
possibilities and this from here the
entire you know bow again begins
so this under opening that you guys may
consider in order to
get some you know playbook position with
lots of strategical fight and so yeah
this would be one that I mean that will
be four opens after E for what do you
guys can do but I want to in the end to
show some games from practical like from
practical side of chess how it ended in
one of my games what how I applied those
concept of let's say center pieces
develop and King safety in my game a
long time ago but this will basically
show what you're supposed to do and what
my opening was doing in this game what
you're not supposed to do and I wondered
giving 20 moves so it was pretty short
game and I applied basically those
concepts perfectly in my opinion so
let's see how how it was let me just
open the game
it it was the game from 2012 and I
played against Sylvester Bednarik he was
polish at chess Extraliga so I sprayed
with white d4 I served the game 54 night
of 693 c5 which is not considered
usually as a little bit inaccurate but
it's possible d5 I basically immediately
try to grab the container control over
the center b5 because otherwise I may
have consumed playing c4 or Knight c3
and stopping before b5 so B 5 is
therefore logical Bishop g5 the ballon D
has this been draw by this again pawn
move well or I can develop my pieces and
the black don't necessarily want to
develop the bishop to b7 I think so it
has some drawbacks that's why it is a
little bit like inaccurate like in a
little bit dubious for black to play
like this this is why the openings is
mentioned earlier after D for our it
might be much better than this but it's
okay either way but okay Quinn a5 so
with some sort of random check see free
in my opinion better was just play Queen
b6 if anything just try to take with the
if Bishop f6 then we should take Queen
takes Queen he attack on f6 because
Queen 85 c 394 okay this under sort of
row in order to develop pieces you have
to play with all of them rather than
just make several moves with one piece
in the opening so okay I basically
attacked my business I had to come back
I make also second with my picture but
it doesn't really matter as much because
I can keep this knife from me for very
easily were visual manage for dust
you know good job in terms of putting
some pressure on maybe seven so like
let's say if let's say let's say if
white black would like to play g6 Bishop
g7 then black still can't castle because
it won't listen will be hanging because
of this bishop so it's not so easy for
black to develop here so black 26 mapa
26 9 BD - as I said I'm basically
trading those Knights wish of a 5 is
sort of logical but like as you guys can
see this Bishop is still not even close
to be in the game so and there's a big
problem because with the bishop is not
in the game black can castle here and
this was the entire problem in this game
from my opponent so played it was a free
app to open played 97 and I start
explaining on the kinks in the Queen
side simply by playing a 4 and the idea
is that I want to take advantage of this
Queen on a file that's already in the
game but it's not placed well and sort
of object of my attack with the rook
from a 1 so my often funny - 1 D - I
took the night the idea by taking the
knight is that I want to in case of
before or something out halves maybe see
Foursquare for my knight so also I have
possibly the move lucky for that can
start with so it's like if you know me
lots of lots of possibilities so but why
can't I go to GaN a for he didn't like
playing before but this has also its
drawback because I play for first Bishop
g6 and now rook takes e4 hitting the
Queen again so another so will be like a
second time the black has to move the
Queen and which is definitely not good
because King is still in the center and
if let's say this bishop was easily
developed and King was castled this
Bishop develop and King castled
then it would be alright but in this
position because this King is on
eight black faces Americ yuge problems
and in terms of you know what
what what to do next basically it's hard
to come up the next move because if
Queen b6 for instance the 94 comes to of
Tempe for instance it's not so easy to
react to this also look a six is maybe
possible but then Queen takes b2 so I
had to build also a be careful so 94
math perfect sense so my opponent play
Queen c7 oh by the way looking at this
position from this most three factors as
I mentioned Center and pieces
development piece piece play and King
safety we can easily see the white
control the center because of those two
pawns I'll maybe take this away what
controls the center has full control of
the center pieces one two three sort of
four even though Queen hasn't moved yet
Queen sort of in the game because
supports the rook on a four and yet
basically supports the roof so basically
four pieces and in the game while black
has in their world place because rook
attacks the Queen Bishop prevents sort
of like development on the all of the
Kings side full of black and firmly to
may come to c4 at some point so what
pieces are well placed well black has to
run the Queen away 907 doesn't do
anything probably the best piece but
ambition is terrible because it stays in
the way of development of development of
this Bishop with GC we should be seven
right now is impossible because simply
this Bishop is blocking it so
peace but as much but you know pieces
here and also King finally the king the
King blacks King is the center in the
center and there's no easy way of
getting the king side and to be safe
while White's King basically just I just
need to move the bishop and Castle
kingside
and that's it basically my fully
developed here and I'm enjoying my
position basically so my game have been
Queen c7 and so what I'm doing which
should be five painting here and
developing my my bishop and I want to
just castle and this position was just
overwhelming basically my open played a
5 which is the move I didn't really
understand but problem position was
already very bad played castle
I played castle and continued developing
my pieces it's a five right now and this
I think was a very very important moment
because if I if I haven't okay I've had
to ask myself what my opponent wants and
basically he wants to play Bishop e7 and
finally even if I take let's say for
instance if a page just run the mood a
group when it's done a good move for
life for instance if we should be seven
if I play the same Bishop Jerry heekin
castle already and suddenly he finish
his development so I don't wonder and
Bishop takes in 1737 he managed to trade
pieces and his King actually in the
center is also okay so and having that
in mind that position is closed because
he saw a star country also the center if
survived for the center with this move
e5 it's not so easy anymore for me in
this position that okay if still I'm
much better because I had the C 4 square
from my knight and basic display the
weakness right now but like considering
what options I have here in this
position after a five I don't really
want to allow him just such as
development we should be some King 7 and
or or castle that's why in here I played
detects a six which is n Poisson and
white here three opens the center
because blacks King is in the center
hasn't castle yet
and
launching an attack basically so f takes
694 and right now the idea could be I
may just attack this pawn somehow I can
play maybe 500 at some point I can play
let's say f4 f5 also I have so many
ideas I can also play queen g4 there I
mean there are lots of also Bishop d3
there are lots of ideas here provided
like what can do it to basically matter
of choice so my opponent and the thing
is the block is still has problems with
development of pieces so basically
probably the best move was still Bishop
e7 but I wouldn't be surprised I'm
always fellas tactically but anyway
having his King in the center I can even
just take take and play maybe a four or
something
also it's possible to play queen g4 so
like there are many moves that basically
white can play and have really you know
attacking regular attacking position so
I haven't played rugby eight I played
Luke takes a5 just grabbing the free
porn so he took money for taking sperm
but the proud of this move why was it
play Bishop this move Bishop e7 because
in here yes he gets this eforp on that's
true but if you guys noticed still those
pieces are not in the game and he hasn't
moved them yet and suddenly after very
simple move that I played here rook e1
finally the last piece comes into the
game because if this pleasure is very
very Stratos all my pieces are in the
game even though my queen hasn't moved
yet on d1 it's also in the game because
put some pressure on d6 so basically my
knight both bishops and Bob rooks are in
the game Queen as well
King is safe while black has played only
with Bishop several times all three
times with the Queen some random of the
rook and King is derive is paint on this
in here and the most pieces are still
not developed they are still in the
in the middle of the board the Kings in
the middle of the board and Bishop on a
very big initiative has made any moves
yet and suddenly black faces huge
problem because this bishop only four is
under attack and because of this if out
pressure here blight is like basically
just winning here so Marvin tried to
defend the knight the bishop I mean it
was d5 but this on the other hand opens
this diagonal and I make me use of
another plane ship ship free and
suddenly black collapses on this
diagonal and loses material so my
opening here plays play Queen takes a
five probably hoping on Knight xa5 right
to then Luke takes d5 and hoping for
some conversation however positions
obviously does a sequin a four but I
don't even need to do this because I can
first take Bishop 67 with the idea
yeah Bishop takes the sorry we should
take ste seven and if King discern I can
take them then the Queen for free
basically and after Bishop takes d7 my
opponent resigned so if you guys noticed
black hasn't moved bishop on a value
rocker nitrate king is only eight under
attack like this is Queen and this is
basically game game over
so yeah this with this game
I just wanted to basically show all the
concept that we learned today how
important it is to basically play all
the pieces what kind of openings there
exists and what you should do in the
opening rather than just randomly moving
points even though they make attack
something it's better to still develop
pieces having mine longer sort of
perspective to develop all the pieces
and attempt to
you know get some playbook position
rather than just create one frets that
basically white or blinds who are
playing with and against can easily deal
with and then white then and then the
opponent can basically take advantage of
your weaknesses as we said in the palm
play basically why was creating by was
creating lots of weaknesses that white
fur was excessively exploited and
finally the night day the king was
getting made it so same thing here a
black was making some random pawn moves
some random piece moves move the same
pieces not trying to develop this Bishop
on a fire broke out no h8 and here the
game simply ended very quickly in 20
moves sim because of all the flaws that
all the strategy my own and employed
head so I hope you find it interesting
and and instructive as well so I think
that would be sort of all of what I have
for today and thank you guys and until
next time bye